[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
Kesha Is With Us in Atlanta hi Kesha
welcome to the Ramsey Show hey Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
so um my husband and I got married about
four months ago
congratulations thank you we're both
very excited about
it so we've begun the process of um
combining money but I think we've semi
combined it and we have some money
things about to happen and I just have
questions on on how to move forward as
far as money's concerned like what
what's your question sure so um we own
two homes I own a home he owns a home
and um he has a tenant currently but his
home needs some work um more money than
we can afford uh to put into the home to
get what market value calls for it so uh
he's made the decision to go ahead and
sell the home um I make probably 80 to
90 a year and he's making about 60 65 a
year um I also have a business a
seasonal business that brings in some
some income and
so my income my seasonal business his
Equity his income do we throw all into
the same pot or do I keep my business
separate how does that work
okay the couples that we see that have
the best quality Mar marage and the
highest probability of Building Wealth
combine
everything there's no yours in mind at
all it's all we you become French we
we got it okay got it so it's we we now
own two houses
one he used to live in and one I used to
live in the one he used to live in we
are thinking we should sell it
but it needs some repairs and so we're
trying to figure out what to do with
that I run a business how do I do that
how do I combine the income from that
business into our new household you hear
my pronouns changing yeah there's no
more yours and mine it's all we and our
yeah so we've Jo we've created a joint
account we have a joint account that we
just opened we also have our separate
accounts that our income gets put into
no Reas they should all go in the same
account
gota gotta it forces you it forces you
to combine your
dreams and when you combine your dreams
and you combine your fears you start to
have that now George you and Whitney
have been married how long five plus
years now so you guys went through this
because you were both young
professionals with your own everything
before you got married right we we have
it so simple that it's how did you
combine it though I had my checking
account and I made that a joint checking
account added her to it she closed hers
and now we have a joint checking and a
joint point savings that's it that's it
and so you can do the same with you have
a business checking that's why you keep
your business you have a business
operating account but when you take
money out of the business called profit
or income and it quote comes home then
it goes into the joint account and it's
part of our
income does that make sense yeah that
makes sense and I guess you know any
expensive what personal expenses like
hair nails whatever it just comes out of
that account the two of you together
talk about your budget before the month
begins we lay out what we are going to
spend our money on and since he's newly
married he's very smart and he's going
to include Hair and Nails in our
budget yeah I think and and all that
makes sense and I think one of our both
both biggest fears is that we both have
children of our own my son um his father
has passed away years ago and so his
care um has always been top of mind for
me and it's scary to let his financial
care just leave my grasp alone you
know how old is your son he's now 19 in
college and so he's still being
financially cared for throughout
physically but your new husband married
into that yeah he knew that you had this
on your heart that you're 19 that you
wanted to continue to give your
19-year-old some support until he
launches into manhood right correct
correct yeah and so we can do that yeah
you know if if Sharon and I had that
situation um you know I know when I'm
marrying into that that this lady has
this son and part of her life and to for
her to not support him is not going to
be okay for a while I mean we don't want
to support him till he's 29 but I mean
but but we want we want to make sure he
gets out there and gets gets a good
start right right exactly and vice vers
for his daughters exactly so just
streamlined this you got one checking
one savings now we can make as many line
items in the budget as we want and
there's just full transparency and
accountability for those items yeah we
have agreed to take care of his daughter
and your son because it's something that
we are concerned about and if he's not
concerned about that about the
19-year-old and you're not concerned
about his daughter you all shouldn't
have gotten married yeah definitely no I
don't think that's the issue I think I
don't think it is either that's what I
mean yeah I mean because it all comes
with a package you don't get to set
these things off to the side in a silo
they're all wrapped together whether you
want them to be together or not and so
that that's why the you know the
marriage vows in sickness and in health
for richer for poorer and the old
marriage vows in the book of common
prayer said unto thee all my worldly
Goods I
pledge I like that that's old school but
uh but you know what the the current
data confirms that that is the best
route relationally and as a probability
for wealth building
it's amazing what happens when you have
shared goals shared dreams shared Vision
shared bank accounts shared fears shared
fears and you put it all out there what
most people do Dave is they brush it
under the rug they keep separate
accounts because it will avoid conflict
which really just means I'm going to
have resentment later it also means also
means I basically have a secret exactly
I'm you know I have a part of my life
that is not that I'm not willing to
share that is not open to to my spouse
ooh danger danger danger danger that's
what most culture tells DAV you got to
have five bank accounts and he's got to
have his and hers no have a one budget
and she can have a line item for hair
care and nails and he can have a line
item for fund money there but that
transparency is what causes marriages to
succeed well that that culture that's
giving that bad advice is the one where
52% of the marriages end and divorce and
they're the ones that stand slack jawed
and look at me with their mouth open and
go you've been married 42 years what's
the secret to a successful man secret
yeah well there it is buddy you know
like
so yeah what the culture you know that's
like you know saying the culture
believes nutrition who cares about this
what this culture believes about
nutrition this culture is obese who
wants to who cares about what this cult
you know this culture says about money
this culture is
broke want to be normal nobody wants to
be normal that's a great question Kesha
thank you for calling in with that and
your sweet Spirit on the way you're
approaching you know I want to give
Kesha a gift can we give her Financial
Peace University and our every dollar
budget app to help them get on this plan
together I think we can that's our a l
light wedding gift I like that we go we
didn't get invited to the wedding but
you'll get a gift a gift anyways Kesha
so hang on the line Austin will pick up
we'll gift you Financial Peace
University watch all nine lessons with
your spouse and work on that budget
together George if she had only known
she would have invited you I'm sure I've
gotten invited before it's very kind but
I go I'm not traveling to Boise
sorry maybe next time create your free
every dooll budget to today the simplest
way to budget for your life